I'm very pleased and honored to have the
opportunity to introduce her vamos he
also reminded me that it should be short
I just very briefly then her vamos grew
up in Long Island he obtained a ba
degree in English literature of all
other topics followed by medical degree
from Columbia University called College
of Physicians and Surgeons following
postdoctoral training at NIH in the
laboratory IRA pastor which few years
later I also spent few years Harold
moved to San Francisco as a member of
the faculty of UCSF for more than 20
years at UCSF he did his groundbreaking
role in cancer on retroviruses for which
he and Michael Bishop shared the Nobel
Prize medicine in addition to his major
scientific achievements Harold served an
important government and administrate
and private administrative positions
from nineteen ninety three to nineteen
ninety nine he served as a director of
the NIH and giving the next dis decade
he served as a president of the memorial
sloan-kettering cancer as you do as of
last year Harold returned to Bethesda to
serve as a director of the National
Cancer Institute hero also serves on the
Council of Advisors of science and
technology of the Obama administration
and very much honored and delighted that
Harold accepted our invitation to
present a lecture at the symposium and
the topic of his lecture is provocative
questions about cancer
was it like that but very good thank you
very much yo see it honored to be
introduced by Yosi who's been a giant in
the field of cell signaling and its
implications for cancer and also it's
illustrated very dramatically and
productively the way in which academics
can move between industry and academia
for the public good well it's daunting
to think about 200 years at Yale Medical
School and it's also daunting to think
that I like many of my fellow
Silverbacks on the program had been
working on our chosen topics for more
than twenty percent of that time now
perhaps not surprising that that a lot
has changed 40 years ago when I started
working on the molecular basis of cancer
we didn't really have tools to do that
and other than some viruses that cause
cancer in animals we didn't know
anything about how a normal cell was
converted into a cancer cell other than
knowing that virus could sometimes do it
and sometimes chemicals could do it all
of our clinical Diagnostics was based on
histology and not on molecules as we are
emphasizing increasingly today and
medical therapies were developed largely
by trial and error and not on
mechanistic rounds we didn't have
targeted therapies we weren't turning
too many cancers into controllable
chronic diseases not that stage nor we
solved that problem yeah well there's a
lot to say about the progress that has
been made over the last 40 years and it
would be normal for me to devote my 40
minutes or whatever to it but you've
already heard about telomerase and
cancer from Liz you've heard about micro
RNAs and cancer from Phil tomorrow
you'll have Charles Sawyer's here to
bring you up to date on many topics
related to targeted therapies you now
have Katie Poletti recently in my lab at
Yale as you can tell you what my labs
been doing recently on lung cancer so
today I'd rather tell you more about
some questions and answers and more
about the future than about the past I'm
doing this at a difficult time in the
history of the NIH the institution which
as you've heard I've recently rejoined
for the first time in my experience the
budget of the NIH has actually been cut
this year and even more difficult and
deeper cuts are under consideration by a
new Congress but today is not a day for
depressing talk and I know it's I I know
it's bad for my telomeres so I will
maintain an optimistic view and talk to
you about what I think we can do with
the with what it has been generously
provided over the years at the NCI we're
struggling to make ends meet this year
we're also trying to make use of the
resources we have and they are
considerable over five billion dollars a
year now a significant part of what we
are trying to do with the NCI is to try
to define what we don't know and and and
find answers to the questions that are
implicit in the notion that we still
don't know a lot and in some instances
it's pretty easy to try to define and
make concerted efforts to answer some
fairly obvious questions let me give you
some examples for example I think
probably everybody in this audience
knows that we have a major challenge
ahead of us as a cancer research
community to define the full repertoire
of molecular changes in burial and the
many types of cancer that effort is
being spearheaded at the NCI but the
Cancer Genome Atlas where we look at
gene expression profiles and and
rearrangements of DNA and mutations in
DNA micro RNA expression methylation
patterns and join that to other kinds of
investigation of changes in protein
levels and protein modifications
telomere length and many other things
second we want to know which of those
changes offer targets for new therapies
which provide opportunities for new
kinds of diagnosis or for ways to
monitor the success of treatments or the
choice of therapies and we seek to
understand how how resistance to various
kinds of therapies conventional or new
targeted therapies arise and how we can
get around those resistance mechanisms
but in addition to these mainstream set
of questions that we all know are a
exciting because we're getting
productive answers already and we have
new therapies look great a lot of things
coming down the pipeline but in addition
to this class of questions that come
quite readily to mind and need to be so
they're there another another class that
comes less readily to mind and needs to
be solicited in a community-wide effort
and then explored vigorously by our
great pool of scientific talent and we
especially need to do that in my view
when funds are tight we call this effort
the provocative questions initiative and
let me tell you a little bit about what
we're trying to do so at the NCI we're
trying to develop a list of questions
that are important but maybe less
obvious in this area and we have so many
obvious things to do and we want to use
these questions to stimulate our
research communities to use all of our
sciences whether laboratory sciences
clinical research or population-based
sciences in particularly effective ways
and we view these questions as questions
that should build on actual observations
that may be solid maybe less solid as
you'll see in my presentation today and
those observations should have the
potential for increasing our
understanding of both cancer and the
means to control it they should address
broad questions and the best questions
will also
have some reasonable likelihood of
progress in the foreseeable future and
these questions when ideally proposed
will show us ways to overcome obstacles
to achieving the long-term goals of
diagnosing treating and preventing
cancer more effectively this exercise is
being undertaken under the direction of
a small team that includes my deputy
director at the NCI glowy famous for his
work on on the grass oncogenes and human
papilloma viruses but virus vaccines
Tyler Jack's in principle Phil sharps
boss is the head of a Koch Institute at
MIT and Ed Harlow who was not long ago
the chairman of biochemistry at Harvard
and that was serving as a special
advisor to me we have a website I'll say
more about that in a moment you can
write down the the URL or you might go
to cancer.gov and make your way to this
site the site is playing in that very
active role in our efforts to to develop
a cohort of important questions now what
I'd like to do today is to take you on a
tour of some of the questions that have
come to our attention through the
various activities we've been carrying
out those include a series of workshops
that have been held at the NIH workshops
that are being organized at various
institutions around the country the yale
organizer is yet to be identified for a
local provocative questions workshop we
are collecting questions to the website
and questions that are posted on the
website are being commented on we have
over a thousand people who have already
registered as active members of the
website and at least a hundred people
who proposed questions on the site what
I'd like to do today to stimulate your
curiosity about this adventure and also
to tell you about some of the things
that many of us see as potentially
provocative and productive topics for
research over the next decade or two is
to take you on a quick tour of
activities of questions have been posed
in a lot of generic
areas of cancer research epidemiology
pathogenesis risk modification
prevention diagnostics and therapeutics
some of this will build on work that
does will be familiar with you some of
it will remind you of what you learned
in in your first introductions to
distribution of cancers around the world
and I hope so that will provoke you to
think about new approaches you might
take to to thinking about or working on
cancer yourself now it's been a little
bit of time in epidemiology I think
because it's a it's an area where there
is a lot of long-standing observation
that has not yet brought us to some of
the deeper conclusions about cancer that
I think will be important to eventual
control both here and importantly around
the world and I won't say much about
this one of the efforts have been making
as director events at the NCI is to
focus our attention more than it has
been focused on efforts to bring cancer
under control in developing countries
where efforts to improve health a focus
mainly on infectious diseases and
there's now an increasing effort to
spend to give greater attention to the
non-communicable disorders such as
cancer which are increasingly prevalent
as a result of our efforts to increase
the lifespan in many countries that have
instituted improved health programs many
of you are familiar with maps like these
that show that the different forms of
cancer that range from gastric cancer up
on your upper left cervical cancer on
the right lung cancer breast cancer and
prostate cancer occur in very
dramatically different patterns which
you see here on these intensity maps is
first of all the fact that the the
distribution of cancers of different
types is dramatically different that the
different parts of the world especially
if you divide the economically advanced
world and say economically backward
less advantageous part of the world
differ dramatically lung cancer for
example having highest rates in US
Canada and Europe including the Soviet
Union where as a disease like cervical
cancer is the most most common in parts
of Africa and South America some a
cancer being much more common in
throughout Asia and Russia and parts of
Latin America we there are many ways in
which one can envision explaining some
of these things the prevalence of
infectious agents that contribute to
cancer in some of these areas those
agents including papilloma viruses
bacteria such as helical bacterium
pylori and others some of the factors
being environmental especially tobacco
use and and and diet and of course a
possible contribution to food inherited
mutations genetics we know that heredity
probably plays a relatively small part
in most of these patterns because
efforts have been made to use the
migration of individuals from one part
of the world to another to assess the
contribution of environment to these
epidemiological patterns so for example
when when people of Chinese ancestry
moved to the US and you compare
chinese-american disease incidence is
shown of a dotted line with that of the
Native America and people have been in
America for several generations and with
native chinese who are still in china
you can see that there's a dramatic
shift in both the incidence of prostate
cancer and the incidence of breast
cancer to the american patterns and
these raised some obvious questions
about what environmental factors are
most critical in in assessing these
these and trying to explain these
dramatic shifts in incidents that occur
when people migrate from one environment
to another in general we've had
difficulty identifying environmental
factors of an other than the tobacco use
and specific viruses in trying to
identify risk factors that seem to be
environmentally based and data sets of
this kind and many others that unless
well studied do provide important clues
that can be studied much more closely
with some of the genomic tools now
available for example to seek
environmental signatures such as those
that are observed in liver cancer that
arise in people exposed to aflatoxin
another another observation that comes
out of long-standing efforts to do
epidemiology are differences in in
cancer in males and females we're all
familiar with an obvious difference that
results from one sex having an organ the
other doesn't have so prostate cancer
understandably is not very common in
women but what is largely forgotten
these discussions the large number of
cancers that have a markedly increased
rate of both incidents and death in
males versus females males is I think
most people know cause a higher
frequency of deaths among males and
females by modest margin hope you look
especially at esophageal cancer liver
cancers laryngeal cancers the
distribution differences are very
dramatic and conversely thyroid cancer
much more common in women than in men we
know very little about these differences
they may be explained by by sex hormones
but maybe not and in some cases that may
be a contribution to made by certain
habits like tobacco chewing and other
things but but these are again clues
that deserve a lot more explanation than
they've received to date no the set of
variations has to do with variations in
in age so we have accepted the idea that
cancer is a disease of Aging indeed as
you've heard already today
from mike Marmot cancers are about 80%
of cancers are diagnosed in individuals
over 60 years of age but that doesn't
mean that cancer increases in incidents
in a simplistic mode with age we're all
used to data like this that show that
breast cancer and prostate cancer in
general increase with age some of these
declines here may be related to the
frequency of use of screening or the
willingness to make a diagnosis of
cancer that that occurs at a very late
age in life but what is often forgotten
these discussions are the other cancers
especially pediatric cancers like
retinoblastoma which occur almost
exclusively under the age of five or
cancers like osteosarcoma that occur
most commonly in teenage years in
addition there are other cancers
glioblastoma multiforme a and cancers of
the blood system especially CML and few
others that tend to peak in Middle Ages
and we don't really understand the cell
dynamics and other factors that that
that might be responsible for such
variation for example the number of stem
cells in a particular organ another
feature epidemiology we haven't paid
that much attention to is the question
of why tumors arrives at very different
frequencies in different organs
irrespective of the size or the number
of cells in that organ indeed the heart
which is quite a large organ has many
many many fewer cancers than the
prostate virtually every male has cancer
of the prostate by the time their they
reach the age of the 80 or 90 whereas
hard cancers are extremely uncommon
there are a few sarcomas and
and benign tumors of the heart that have
been encountered and the question of why
hearts don't develop cancers have been
posed to me by two individuals one
cricket sidemen of renowned cardiac
biochemist and physiologist and another
person who proposed this question to me
was John Porter used to be the chairman
of our house appropriations subcommittee
so you can see this this question tracks
wide interest but hasn't been answered
another very intriguing observation is
that colon cancer and colorectal cancer
are is the one of the third leading
causes of cancer mortality in this
country small intestinal cancer and
human beings is virtually not unknown
but it's very very rare despite the fact
that the many features of the the small
intestine resemble those of the large
intestine and in diseases like familial
adenomatous polyposis in which there is
a pre-existing mutation in the tumor
suppressor gene APC virtually all the
tumors arise in the large intestine not
the small we also have a major
discrepancy that been noted by many that
is not always so solid but that suggests
that that animals have very different
sizes have different and sometimes
paradoxical cancer frequencies so the
mouse with a relatively small short life
span and small size has a very high
frequency of cancers rain differing from
mouse strain to Mouse training
admittedly turtles rarely have cancers
of any kind unless they happen to be
infected with certain turtle specific
strains of papilloma virus sharks have
been alleged never to have cancer and
that led to a whole problem of its own
because you can go to any one of your
local health food stores and buy sharp
shark cartilage on the grounds that this
extract will protect you from cancer it
does not
but it has led the the general belief in
the cancer free nature of sharks has led
to significant decimation of the shark
populations in certain parts of the
world sharks don't have many cancers but
do have some whales are interesting
they're obviously very large a lot of
cells at risk for cancer they live a
long time cancers are quite infrequent
except in one type of way of beluga
whales in the st. Lawrence estuary where
there appear to be there's a high
relatively high cancer frequency there
which probably suggest some specific and
probably informative ideological agent
possibly virus which is causing both
papillomas and papillomas carcinomas and
and breast cancers finally there's
another epidemiological issue that's of
some interest which addresses the
question of whether there may be cross
protection between some diseases we
heard earlier from hood as ugly about
mutations that that lead to rett
syndrome and involved responses to
methylated DNA and one could imagine a
linkage they're not fully explored
between cancer rates and and diseases of
that type but in a number of recent
efforts to look at cancer incidents in
patients with newer generative diseases
a number of intriguing observations have
been made for example in a recent paper
by Rho at all it's been shown that when
you do make a concerted effort and among
Caucasian patients who have been
diagnosed with Alzheimer's the incidence
of cancer appears to be low there was an
effort here to correct for the
likelihood that that an effort to
ascertain cancers in those patients
might be less conversely
patients who who have cancer seem to
have reduced incidence of Alzheimer's
disease and that again was attempt was
made to correct for the obvious bias of
having patients died of cancer before
they reach the age which Alzheimer's
occurs nevertheless this is a these are
provocative observations and they
require for the substantiation and then
an effort to try to understand whether
there's some underlying molecular basis
for this kind of difference it is
encouraging to credit this data given
the fact that when you look at vascular
dementia as opposed to Alzheimer's that
protection against cancer is not
observed now Alzheimer's disease is not
the only neurodegenerative disease in
which some protection against cancers
has been observed in similar
observations with Huntington's disease
Parkinson's disease and fragile x
syndrome and in a set of observations
recently published by Olson at all there
is evidence that that many cancer types
are less frequent in both males and
females with darkensens disease and at
the same time there are at least two
fairly common cancers breast in
malignant melanoma that occur at an
enhanced frequency in both sexes in
patients with parkinson's disease
whether this has some relation to some
subtype of Parkinson's or whether it's
related to mutations in the parkin gene
or other genes that may be predisposing
to to Parkinson's remains to be
understood but these are clearly again
provocative observations let me say a
few things about pathogenesis one can
argue that epidemiology itself can
inform the study of pathogenesis since
patterns of cancer incidents may help to
identify causative agents such as
viruses or sunlight or tobacco and one
very striking thing from a slide I
showed you earlier is the despite the
very wide prevalence of a major
causative agent of gastric cancer namely
he let go back to your pylori cancer
incidents a stroke cancer incidence
varies dramatically
around the world and it's not especially
clear as yet why this why these
differences are so profound over 10 or
20 or 30 fold one clue comes from a
recent study carried out by SAP lat at
all just published and got this year in
which an effort was made to understand
very profound differences in the
incidence of gastric cancer in Columbia
South America where the distribution of
h pylori is basically universal but the
incidence of gastric cancer is 25 fold
higher in mountainous regions that in
coastal regions and by looking at
isolates of h pylori from many patients
in these two locations they developed
the group of scientists who published
this paper developed a genealogical tree
and showed that that the gastric cancer
tended to be associated with possibly
due to the carriage of h pylori that has
European rather than African origins and
it studies like this that seemed to me
to suggest that a much closer look at
microbial flora and carrying out what
kept with the kind of sub speciation is
now possible with with high throughput
DNA sequencing may be a very useful
exercise that leads to specific changes
in the in the way in which we attempt to
change the flora to control against
cancer a recent publication from drug
cartels group parnell's group and
hopkins gives another perspective on
this kind of study this is a study
carried out in a mouse model based on
the APC mutation that I mentioned
earlier these mice so-called min mice
have a mutation in one copy of the APC
gene and without any further
perturbation of these animals develop
small intestinal tumors at very high
frequency in contrast the colonic tumors
that are seen in human beings who have
not only the same mutated gene but it's
exactly the same kind of the very same
mutation frame should
mutation in a PC hey an organism which
has been thought to have aquagenic
properties in enterotoxigenic bacterias
fragilis has been instilled in these
animals to see their effect on the
development of tumors and the intriguing
observation recorded in these pictures
is that large intestinal colonic tumors
arise at high frequency in min mice that
that carry certain strains of
enterotoxigenic bacillus fragilis and
this again illustrates the potential
power of looking more closely at the
microbiome which we used to call it the
intestinal flora to attempt to identify
specific organisms that may be making
specific factors that are contributor to
neoplasia now an underlying problem in
trying to understand patterns of uncle
gene mutation or tumor suppressor gene
mutation and the development of certain
kinds of tumors has been the observation
that that many tumor types are
specifically associated often at very
high frequency with certain kinds of
mutations think rass mutations occurring
it in virtually every case of pancreatic
carcinoma think of the high frequency of
grass EGF receptor or Alf mutations in
certain kinds of lung cancer think about
the essential universal appearance of a
able gene translocation with activation
of the April kinase and CML and it's
long been assumed that the association
of these mutations with a specific tumor
type reflects some property of the
context in which those genes that those
cancer genes are active and the
consequence for the cell dependent on on
context but that hand waving about
context seems to me to provide a
tremendous opportunity for identifying
other factors in pathogenesis that maybe
therapeutic targets a good example of
how we
proceed to understand the molecular
significance in the mechanistic
explanation of these contextual effects
is presented in the paper by giad
offices Charles Sawyer's group last year
Charles tells me he's not talking about
this tomorrow if I'm not overlapping
with him but would Charles and his
colleagues did was to take notice of the
fact that that gastrointestinal stromal
tumors which are almost always
associated with mutations either in the
PDGF receptor or in the kit
transmembrane tyrosine kinase arise from
the interstitial cells of Cahal in the
intestinal epithelium and by pooling
gene expression data from several
previously published studies they
identified 11 genes that are nearly all
common 22 jiss in all three studies than
by using knockdown approaches with with
with with hairpin micro RNAs they
identified a transcription factor known
as ETB one as a important target that is
expressed in in both normal because halt
cells and in gastrointestinal stromal
tumors and have proposed very simplistic
mechanism but one that suggests that
normal interstitial cells of k'hal
development under the influence of
moderate levels of expression of etv
with signaling through the kit pathway
in in cells and acquire a Kip mutation
the signaling is intensified and as long
as etv one is present high levels of
expression of genes that contribute to
the neoplastic phenotype occur so this
suggests that that in addition to
targeting kit as is commonly done with
the magnet on the treatment of gist
there are other targets in this pathway
as well as the potential for interfering
with the function of the TV or other
ways in which etv protein is known to be
regulated both
transcriptional and protein degradation
levels what's to talk a little bit about
risk modification in the arena of cancer
research in which we all work today
there's of course tremendous excitement
about exploiting our understanding of
cancer genomics to develop new therapies
and much of the cancer advocacy that we
all hear about comes from people
understandably who have cancer now and
and seek to harness what we've learned
about cancer to develop new therapies
but understanding risk modifying it
trying to prevent cancers with the
various interventions are very important
part of what we do with the NCI and I
believe a very important part of what
cancer control is all about will never
succeed completely by doing this kind of
thing we can succeed to a very large
extent indeed the declining cancered
incidents and death rates that have been
observed in this country over the last
10 to 20 years are very significantly
attributed the tribute about 22 behavior
modification with respect to smoking
indeed tobacco use is the the arena in
which we can take most cut most pride in
our ability to control cancer in this
country but we also know that there is a
large segment of the population has been
refractory to the two efforts to modify
behavior and reduce cancer rates still
further and we need to ask the question
of why we don't we aren't able to to
modify behaviors in these individuals
there are at least three general
categories of insufficient understanding
that behavioral scientists who come to
our provocative questions workshops have
talked to us about one is that we don't
design the message optimally here I give
you four examples of messages that have
appeared on cigarette packages for
example or possibly the message isn't
effectively deliberate maybe this
shouldn't just be or this shouldn't be
mainly on tobacco packages
on top of things and then we have
perhaps not done what can be done in
talking to or otherwise preparing mines
to to accept the the implications of
these efforts to change behavior and
maybe a little more training of
receptive minds is the thing that needs
to be done another factor in concurring
risk of cancer is obesity this has been
known for some time the most persuasive
paper is the paper by khalid all and
appear in the New England Journal about
eight years ago and what these folks
show is that that especially when one
looks at the highest strata of
overweight individuals in this country
that that the risk of cancers of many
types especially as you can see here for
women uterus kidney cervix pancreas
esophagus and in men as well in this
case liver pancreas and stomach and
esophagus is in the range of two to five
times higher overall two and a half
times increased incidence and in the
particular specially Abby's cohort about
population and the the author's
speculate in the discussion that if
obesity were completely eliminated in
this country not something which is
going to happen overnight that we could
reduce the number of deaths from cancer
in this country from its current 560,000
or so by about 90,000 that's a very big
cut in the overall cancer mortality wait
as you know cancer obesity is a growing
phenomenon in this country and
throughout both the developed and the
developing world these this shows
graphically how rapid the increase in
obesity has been so simple control of
obesity by the kinds of measures
currently
in existence or not particularly
effective so it's hard right now to do a
study in which you attempt to ascertain
whether you can reverse the risk of
cancer by reversing obesity there is
however a extreme measure that has been
taken in many patients and that is to
carry out what's called Perry afrik
surgery and to my performing
gastrointestinal reorganization lower
weight pretty dramatically and as this
chart shows must study that appeared a
couple of years ago in the New England
Journal one can reduce all death by all
causes by roughly two fold even over a
period is short as seven years and when
all of the numbers of deaths from cancer
are relatively small here it's clear
that there's about two and a half fold
reduction in cancer rates as a result of
bariatric surgery and the attendant
weight loss and obviously confirmatory
data are going to be required but this
is a very encouraging piece of
information to suggest that we ought to
understand this much more profoundly
what is it about obesity that
contributes to cancer risk is it an
inflammatory process is it the weight
itself is it are there hormonal factors
that are either expressed by fat cells
by cells that govern appetite that also
have an effect on the propensity of
cells to become cancerous and my view
this is a very important area for study
that's been under worked let me say a
little bit more about the prevention of
a more conventional sort that uses
actual interventions as opposed to
simply identifying risks and thinking
about ways to modify them I think
probably everybody here is familiar with
the idea that there are quite a few
drugs that are in very very common use
in this country statins aspirin some
certain drugs for diabetes and others
that there are large cohorts of
individuals who are taking these drugs
on a daily basis for long periods of
time this is a natural kind of
experiment comparative effectiveness
research can have its beginnings here
on January first of this year a group of
individuals headed by Rothwell published
a paper in Lancet in which they
published a which they summarized a
meta-analysis of seven large-scale
studies of individuals who are taking
aspirin for protection against
cardiovascular events and overall what
was observed was that after about five
years of chronic use of aspirin it was a
very significant difference in death
rates from cancer with aspirin use
protecting these individuals by about
the extent of about twenty percent
moreover when you look cancer by cancer
you've learned to fear some cancers such
as esophageal stomach colorectal and
lung cancer all of which show quite
dramatic effects especially for
esophageal cancer and colorectal cancer
and contrast there a number of cancers
the pancreas prostate kidney blood
system in which the effects are small or
non-existent so this seems to be
somewhat tissue-specific more people
would be using aspirin if we could
somehow prevent or bypass the potential
hemorrhagic effects of using aspirin
chronically and it would be my view very
useful to try to understand whether
aspirin is actually working as an
anti-inflammatory agent or by some other
mechanism if it's working in an
anti-inflammatory way what is the
component of the inflammatory phenomena
that that is being interfered with by by
aspirin can be developed agents that
could be used chronically that that
confer the same benefit of protection
from cancer without incurring the risk
of intestinal hemorrhage let me say
something about about diagnostics here
we get into an area which is obviously
going to be very heavily influenced by
the
massive and exciting efforts that are
being made in cancer genomics but there
are a few questions that are worth
focusing on more specifically and we
know we all want to develop Diagnostics
that allow us to say which drugs
individual should and shouldn't and
should not get but some of that is
should be dependent not just on deciding
what the targets are for drugs but also
on what the what the the the pathogenic
potential of any lesion might be because
of more intensive screening and better
histopathology we're all now familiar
with a variety of neoplastic lesions
ranging from colonic polyps not shown
here to prostatic preneoplastic lesions
non-invasive intraepithelial neoplasia
the ductal carcinoma in situ is very
commonly seen in women in this country
and can be detected by mammography even
pancreatic intrepid Theo Leone aplasia
has been identified and individuals who
have been examined surgically for
prostate cancer or or for prostatitis
pack of pancreatitis sorry and in each
of these cases we are at a loss to know
the likelihood that these disorders are
going to proceed to an invasive frankly
carcinoma to state and paying more
attention to this issue is going to have
an effect not just on drug choice but
also on the general vigor with which
therapies are are pursued conversely we
need to understand more more profoundly
the significance of finding cells from a
primary tumor at basically metastatic
cited a different site and while the
alarm bells will always go off when we
find cancer cells at a distance site
we're not really sure that that alarm
bells should always go off here is an
example of a so-called sentinel lymph
node that was invaded by a ductal breast
cancer primary in the breast to
to illustrate this point because just
this year a consortium of surgeons
around the country published a paper in
which they showed that individuals who
simply have a biopsy and removal of a
sentinel lymph node the lymph node to
which the breast primarily acts as a
primary site for for grass drainage
compared to full accelerated section
which was in prior years the standard of
care for treatment of breast cancer that
did show spread of breast cancer cells
to the sentinel node as you can see
whether you simply measure individuals
who are alive after surgery that
includes includes Axler lymph node
dissection full removal of excellent
lymph nodes or just sentinel lymph node
dissection alone or whether one looks
both the disease free and alive patients
really are indistinguishable in these
two groups actually looks here as though
there's a slight advantage to only
having had the the sentinel lymph node
dissection so clearly there are
situations in which the finding of a
disseminated cell growing in another
site is not a reason to to carry out
extensive surgery a couple of words
again about therapeutics just to
emphasize a couple of points we all know
that there are traditional cancer
treatments that very often work or
sometimes derided as being cut poison
and burn but the fact the fact is that
surgery is our major defense against
cancer mortality at this point that
radiotherapy does cure some individuals
and is a tremendous benefit and has
gotten much more sophisticated in recent
years as head surgery chemotherapy tends
to be viewed with a fair amount of
disrespect even though
I would contend that it has prolonged
lives more importantly we tend to forget
that some disseminated cancers are cured
by chemotherapy alone the classical
example that everybody in this room
knows about his testicular cancer and
Laurent Lance Armstrong had metastatic
testicular cancer involving the the
lungs and brain and yet went on to win
seven tours de France and he is not
alone not roughly ninety five percent of
patients with testicular cancer can be
cured with cisplatin an agent which is
of only modest benefit in certain other
and most other cancers which it's used
the ovary long and many other organs and
we have other cancers lymphomas and
leukemias some other germ cell tumors
that can be cured with conventional
chemotherapy in my view even though
we've known this for some years we've
given insufficient attention to the
characteristics of these tumors and the
way in which these drugs work and to try
to understand more profoundly why some
chemotherapies that tend to be derided
actually are quite effective in certain
situations so there are a wide range of
things we haven't been paying that much
attention to we need to think about much
more profoundly I hope that the
provocative questions exercise will help
us to focus on some of those questions
for those who are concerned about the
availability of grants to work on these
things the NCI will be issuing an RFA
sometime in the near future to to study
provocative questions that are coming
from our website and I urge all of you
at Yale elsewhere to participate in this
community effort to draw our attention
to some of the most profound questions
in cancer research that perhaps aren't
getting all the funds and attention that
we're giving to cancer genomics and in
cancer therapeutics thanks very much